mona hamou dès lors c'était juste avant
de questionner votre invité
on a aperçu tout à l'heure des blessés
certains manifestants certains tant pis
être pris en charge par des scripts mais
dit qu est-ce que vous avez des
informations sur des éventuelles
blessures aujourd'hui
alors écoutez grégory je n'ai pas les
chiffres exacts en cours en tout cas
j'ai pu constater j'ai pu le voir y ait
quelques blessés en effet qui ont été
pris en charge soit par des pompiers
soit par des street mehdi qui ont été
blessé à la jambe ou encore à la tête
également dg les jeunes qui étaient
présents lors de de ceux de ce
rassemblement et dans ce cortège aussi
qu'ils étaient vraisemblablement des
street
medic également et qui ont aidé qui ont
secourus ces gens là il ya eu plusieurs
distributions de liquide pour ceux qui
avaient qui avait reçu du gaz
lacrymogène on a été également nous a
gentiment également donné un peu de
celui qui pour pouvoir ouvrir les yeux
et puis voir un peu plus clair en tout
cas pour le moment le hockey c'est un
peu plus calme quoique vous l'entendez
juste derrière moi savary c'est assez
inattendu
je vais donner je vais laisser la parole
à un sapeur-pompier bons joueurs en vue
merci d'être avec nous vous êtes venu du
vaucluse pour présenter oui bonjour donc
plutôt moche et je suis sapeur pompier
professionnel dans le vaucluse à avignon
est également président du syndicat
autonome du 84 pourquoi c'est important
pour vous manifester depuis juin 2019
j'ai pu parler à plusieurs collègues qui
nous est extrêmement important de
manifester manifester surtout
qu'aujourd'hui il ya cette réunion avec
le gouvernement qu'est ce que vous
attendez
mais en fait on attend enfin que le
gouvernement nous comprenne
nous entendons nous comprennent surtout
on a des revendications qui pour nous
sont légitimes
nous avons un stream de feu qui est
existe depuis 1993 qui n'a toujours pas
été réévalué depuis donc on attend à ce
que justement la revalorisation par dans
ce face et
et il y aura pris au bout si bien
d'autres sujets que notamment la réforme
sur les retraites où on est également
impactée on a roulé en retraite un peu
de départs à la retraite anticipée c'est
ça alors c'est oui sociaux on peut dire
ça c'est on a la possibilité de partir
cinq ans avant mais sous certaines
conditions
c'est à dire qu'il faut avoir travaillé
au minimum 27 ans et avoir surcotiser
c'est à dire qu'on nous fait c'est pas
un cadeau qu'on nous fait c'est une
surcotisation que le pays et tous les
tous les mois qui est de l'ordre de 4 %
de plus sur leurs cotisations retraite
aujourd'hui le lait pour sa part
confiant une heure où ils jouissent
d'une bonne réputation autour d'une
bonne image de cent de la population
quels sont les coulisses du métier à
jouer j'ai pu parler avec beaucoup de
pompes qui m'expliquent ce n'est pas un
mais c'est extrêmement pénible oui en
fait c'est surtout les rythmes de
travail qui sont compliquées nous
faisons des gardes de 24 heures donc que
nous arrivait de
des gardes et ne pas dormir
physiologiquement c'est compliqué donc
on demande aussi au niveau national que
soit enfin pris en compte cette
pénibilité au travail et surtout de
d'organiser nos temps de travail un
organisme point des gardes de 12 heures
c'est sûr que là actuellement il faut
comprendre qu'elle sapeurs pompiers qui
travaillent et 24 heures des pays en
moyenne que 17 ou 18 ans sur ces 24
heures en plus on a vu ici
la tension monte d'un cran il a eu ces
frictions
est-ce que les pompiers sont sont
taboues finalement oui bien sûr c'est
justement parce que le mouvement dure
depuis joué que le gouvernement qu'on
arrive à des situations comme ça qui
doit les augmenter
on a envie de comparer deux et qu'on va
en faire mais on les comprennent ce que
je suis et tout bon selon vous cette
mobilisation elle va perdurer
on attend de voir l'évolution je te
demande de la réunion qui a vu
aujourd'hui si les évolutions sont
favorables pour notre corporation
on pourra éventuellement arrêter le
mouvement tout au moins de diminuer
est ce que vous êtes optimiste
finalement optimiste pour la majorité
des revendications je sais pas mais
nous on demande surtout à ce qui est
vraiment une composition de notre métier
ont créé une filière sapeurs-pompiers
actuellement on est fonctionnaire
territoriaux mais on n'est pas
réellement un métier à part c'est pour
ça qu'on a des difficultés à faire
connaître notre métier justement on
avait vu c'est cette friction qu'il a eu
tous alors on les voit souvent dans les
manifestations des gilets jaunes doigts
et des syndicats est ce que finalement
c'est pas un cri de colère de la part
des sapeurs pompiers
mais c'est ça c'est le rat le ras le bol
qui s'exprime là forcément avec des
échauffourées un petit peu avec les
forces de l'ordre et le fait qu'ils
aient cette confrontation avec la police
et pompiers ce que c'est pas paradoxal
un petit peu paradoxal après là pour les
stars la situation reste on va dire à
distance il faudrait pas que c'est un
bienne a du corps encore là où par
contre là ça deviendrait compliqué et
pour les la police arrête image de la
police et puis donc si on n'est pas venu
là non plus pour se battre donc le
mouvement ils restent mobilisés c'est ça
oui tout à fait oui le mouvement pour
les sens il est toujours là et toujours
on est tous remobilisés en attend
justement les retours de
de cette réunion pour voir un petit peu
si on peut regagner dans nos maisons
très bien merci beaucoup à vous pour ce
témoignage grégory vous l'avez entendu
on va essayer de se rapprocher un petit
peu de deux pourvois c'est de voir un
petit peu ce qui se passe alors vous le
voyez là il y à prendre juste devant
cette barry can alors qu' il y à
quelques mythes et a été a été noire de
monde
et là vous le voyez il ya ces tirs de
gaz lacrymogènes et tirs de gaz
lacrymogène pardon qui ont été lancées
par les forces de l'ordre pour essayer
tant bien que mal de disperser disperser
les manifestants les sapeurs pompiers à
l'origine on l'a vu il ya eu un un pont
de tension assez intense tout à l'heure
entre les forces de l'ordre et ses
pompiers une confrontation assez
impressionnant puisqu'il y avait cette
barricade qui est juste mais derrière
moi et derrière cette barricade il ya
les canaux où il ya les forces de
l'ordre elle a été bousculée permettant
à certains pompiers d'y accéder puis
elle a été refermé les portes ont
rapidement repris le dessus vous le
voyez ici avec des manifestants des
sapeurs pompiers qui continue d'essayer
de s'en approcher un peu plus donc
l'ambiance ici en elle elle varie en
fait ça peut aller très bien comme la
seconde après l'ambiance peu à peu se
tendre en tout cas ils restent ici pour
la dispersion n'a pas encore commencé
certains valaient à bastille et d'autres
veulent aller sur d'autres endroits pour
continuer à nous
il valait les sapeurs-pompiers veut
qu'on entende leurs cris scolaire merci
mon âme ou dès lors en direct de la
place de la nation